[Music]
son what does it go for Bill can you say
it well who
knows a really rich doctor said you were
a bummer and I think you don't know
algebra no we're talking science Bud the
science of what is that a tiger one of
your friends promised me I could flick
you in your face absolutely you may not
do that hit him in his cringy smirk for
real I brought the T
tiger really you got somebody on the
organ
now hey man you're going to pay for
dinner you're going to no a
stupid that's good that's just good
stuff that's the fine folks over at bad
lip reading I saw that one yesterday I
wanted to show that to you have you guys
ever seen any of those bad lip reading
things they used to do them I don't know
how often they're doing them anymore but
they always used to do them uh during
the debates and during you know big
talks and state of the union and that
kind of stuff they just they just do
great stuff hope you enjoyed the little
cold open for you it is October 5th 2023
I'm Dave Ruben this is the Ruben report
I'm feeling good about our color
combination today we are live streaming
on Rumble locals and YouTube and if you
want to join us for a postgame show
today and always Ruben report.
locals.com we're going to get into a
couple stories up top today and then we
are doing a community Q&A so if you want
to get some questions on the Fly Brock
are you connected to the internet right
now Brock is on the internet via his
phone and computer and if you want to
communicate with us directly right now
during the show Ruben report. locals.com
maybe you can get a question or a
comment in on this Live program that
we're doing right now uh the topic
before we get to all of that today uh
will be about genitals are yours
attached to you if they are consider
yourself in the one % people uh yes this
trans epidemic and I don't know any
other way to describe it uh continues to
grow and we have a a sort of policy
layer of people that are pushing it on
us an Institutional layer a political
layer an educational layer all of those
things and a whole bunch of people
fortunately you know this is one of the
things that the left and the wers do
that actually helps us I think in the
long term they push so far that they
take people who are pretty much checked
out who think everything's going to be
okay and they actually wake you up we
know that this is happening with parents
all over the country right now and that
there is finally a little bit of a push
back against some of this gender stuff
specifically we should probably be
pushing more against some of the race
stuff and some of the stuff about the
founding of the country and a bunch more
but at least on the gender front it
seems like we're getting some wins so
we're going to talk a bit about that
using clips from Two Fellas you might
have heard of Tucker Carlson and Joe
Rogan I'm told they're on the internet
those guys they are on the internet uh
and we'll get to all that in just a
moment let me talk to you guys about my
Pat Supply do you get the feeling
something Unthinkable is going to happen
soon we did we did all get a emergency
message at 3:00 yesterday which freak
the kids out in my house uh well guys
with all the distractions and smoke
screens in the media we probably won't
see it coming that's why it's smart to
invest in emergency food today A wise
man once said it's better to have it and
not need it than need it and not have it
my Patriot suppli is the nation's leader
in emergency food storage go to my
website prepare with ruben.com and
you'll save 25% on my Patriot supplies
3month emergency food kit you'll enjoy a
wide variety of delicious meals
providing over 2,000 calories a day for
Optimum strength under stress stock up
now before everyone else panics free
shipping is automatic and your order
ships fast go to prepare with ruben.com
prepare withth ruben.com prepare with me
and now back to me all right let's talk
a little bit about this uh trans
situation because as I said they they
push so hard most people I think we've
all learned this after years of coid and
everything El most people kind of accept
being abused most people kind of accept
being lied to most people kind of accept
their rights being trampled on and
everything else and then every now and
again they push so hard that even the
average person who's kind of Live and
Let Live starts getting annoyed you know
when you're let's say I don't know your
seven-year-old son comes home and sends
says he's a girl might be a little bit
jarring for you well the push back on
this is really breaking forth and uh Joe
Rogan was talking about sort of the
trans ideology and how it's especially
being pushed on kids and he was getting
a lot of heat for what he said here take
a look when you think like that like
someone could steal your kids like
that's real someone could hurt your kids
and someone you know could go in the
locker room and watch your kid go to the
bathroom because they decide that
they're a girl and that doesn't mean
that there's not people that are
legitimately trans and identify as women
and that's who they are and they're not
perverts and they're not creeps of
course of course course that exists too
but you're opening the door if someone
just says I'm trans I can use that
restroom you're opening the door for
perverts you 100% most certainly are
this doesn't deny the existence of trans
people but we have to be honest about
what could possibly happen that's why if
people are uncomfortable with biological
males walking around female locker rooms
is cuz some people are liars and they're
con artists and they're not really it's
this person that's like been trapped in
a man's body their whole life they're
perverts and they want to be
around kids or they want to be around
women they want to make them
uncomfortable they want people to stare
at their dick while they walk around and
know that they can't say anything about
it that's real too sure that's real too
this doesn't discount the the problem
that trans people have with integrating
into society and being accepted that's
real too that's real too but you have to
understand that if you just have this
blanket policy where no one can question
anything about this stuff you're you're
opening the door to abuse so the reason
I wanted to show you that clip is not
because Rogan said anything what in that
should be deemed controversial right
there uh but in this wacky time we live
in he's getting a ton of push back on
that and I have no doubt that some of
the activist organizations will be
calling on Spotify to get rid of him and
he's a trans fob and all that but if you
really listen to what he said there he's
giving it the most soft gloves treatment
possible he's saying yes there is a
certain amount of these people that do
exist right but we have to figure out
how to integrate them into so to society
and while we're doing that you want to
make sure that the Bad actors the guy
who Suddenly at 45 wants to put on a
dress so that he can go into a woman's
locker room at the gym and show off his
Wang uh you don't want to empower that
guy you don't want to empower the people
that are trying to confuse children
about their gender identity and those
things so he's doing it as softly as
possible but as you guys know when you
do this softly when you give the left an
inch on almost anything they don't care
right like they don't take that
qualification you've heard me talk about
these issues all the times what what do
I always say I say you gotta you can't
have the public officials talking to
kids about this stuff it would be for a
parent to deal with or a family
psychiatrist or psychologist that that
part's obvious um but the idea that
Society is sort of upending all of our
Norms who can be in what bathroom who
can be in what Locker what teachers can
talk to kids about privately and hide
from parents that we're upending all of
those things although we are reversing
that here in the Free State of Florida
uh it's actually dangerous so I want to
go to something else that was going
around yesterday uh Tucker Carlson on
his new show on X Twitter uh had a
policy expert who's now done a
documentary uh about the trans what he
calls trans Inc his name is Chris meritz
uh and he talked a bit with Tucker about
the financial incentives behind this
growing industry of basically taking
children and transitioning them
transitioning them into the other gender
in terms of uh the the the pace of
growth for let's say clinics uh serving
pediatric patients on on gender issues
in 15 last 15 years in the United States
we had zero now to over a 100 clinics
clinics for
kids
why it's a very complicated um it's a
very complicated question and there's a
lot of different reasons why um I I
would say that the biggest single policy
Catalyst for this explosion is Obamacare
when ObamaCare was uh enacted in 2010
there was a kind of very
quietly um uh uh kind of written into
the law a provision in which insurance
companies were mandated to to provide
coverage for what is deemed to be
medically necessary gender affirming
care as a result of that between 2010
and
2016 there was a 50% increase increase
in sex reassignment surgeries 25%
increase in um uh ins uh insurance cover
insurance coverage for transgender
individuals uh and then at the very end
of the Obama Administration
2016 an additional Amendment to the
Affordable Care Act was made
whereby uh uh gender identity could no
longer be a basis for denial of
coverage um
uh by private insurance companies as a
result of that the next year 20 from
2016 to 2017 there was 150% increase in
sex reassignment surgeries in the United
States try to write as fast as possible
as I'm listening to him all right there
there's so much there first off
connecting this to Obamacare that there
were Provisions in Obamacare starting in
2010 to affirm right and it's always
that orwellian language affirm gender
identity even though the least affirming
thing you could do is if an
eight-year-old boy says I'm a girl it
would be unaffirmed to say that you're
actually a girl you you'd affirm that
they're a boy and deal with whatever it
is that they're thinking oh I like
Barbie and a boy okay well that's okay
some boys do that maybe he grows up to
be a gay man maybe not right like
they're feminite straight guys they're
straight acting gay guys and all of
those things uh but the idea that this
is connected to Obamacare is super
interesting and that there were then
incentives basically
for all of these clinics I mean he said
we went from zero of these clinics in
2010 to over a hundred of these clinics
now and now we know this thing has burst
forth I want to once again do the I'll
do the soft glove thing even though
there's really no point anymore right
I'm not a bigot or a hater or a racist
or whatever related to any of these
things somehow if you say something
about trans people you're also a racist
you guys know that they combine them all
into one wacky thing but I'll do the
soft Club thing again which is that yes
of course to me to me any adult you're
over 18 you wish to dress the opposite
way and call yourself something
different you should be enti if you
treat people with respect you should be
entitled to respect like it's a two-way
street I don't think you should be
discriminated against people can decide
uh whether they want to be your friend
or not like everyone's discriminatory in
the type of people that they're around
we can all do that but I understand that
there are some people who are not
thrilled with some of my Life Choices
it's the it's the beauty of living in a
pluralistic country with 350 million
some OD people but let's continue
because he dives into a bit more on how
this is so pervasive within our Health
Care system now uh he's going to
reference something called W path in the
in the uh clip we're about to show you
it's the world professional association
for transgender health and listen to how
our health system has been so warped
around
gender una affirming care improve I
can't say whether there were whether
there were peer-reviewed stud studies at
the time um uh I I believe that you know
even today we don't know the long-term
consequences necessarily of some of of
those specific drugs but certainly with
with respect to the transgender uh
Pharmaceuticals there are no longterm
studies uh peer-reviewed that show the
advocacy uh or or not um of of of taking
these very powerful Pharmaceuticals and
um you know we we may not know for some
time uh and in fact what what has
resulted in uh this has resulted in a
situation where clinici and institutions
and academics and elementary schools and
the entire gamut of this supply chain uh
has have to fall back on protocols
established by an organization called
wath wath stands for the world
Professional Association of transgender
Health it's technically a medical uh
professional body established in the
1970s um and um but I think what's
unique about it uh is that it's it is it
is for sure you know a a medical entity
uh but it is also an advocacy
organization and a political advocacy
organiz for sure so in so far as they
are advoc advocating for the advancement
of
transgenderism so in other words
uh the protocols and clinical protocols
that hos Health Systems um you know
large and small that are fall are
falling back on are the standards that
wpath um has enacted over the years all
right so he's making a really
interesting point there the whole system
itself the financial incentives and then
these activist organiz organizations the
system is designed to push more people
to transition what what are the chances
really think about this you bring your
8-year-old daughter to one of these
clinics and your daughter says she's a
boy and you're trying to make some sense
out of it and somehow the whole the the
the education system the cultural
institutions they've all pushed you to
now go to this place do you think
there's any chance at this place they're
going to be like you know what no
actually your your 8-year-old's just a
little bit confused send them home you
know take them for a walk go on vacation
whatever it might be right like clean up
whatever is going on in your own house
have you confused them about gender
roles or or God knows what right like
whatever it might be is there any chance
they turn people around that would be a
great we should get in touch with this
guy that would be an incredible thing to
find out when people go to these gender
clinics with their kids how many people
are turned away or do they affirm what
anyone is thinking regardless of age and
brain development and everything else
right just because you're eight years
old and believe that you're a Sith Lord
it probably isn't true occasionally it
is you got it Anakin you know didn't
work out the way we all wanted but okay
he came around to the end uh anyway
people are waking up on all sides of
this and uh one of the I think bigger
problems that we have right now is that
a lot of the people waking up have been
the very same people who have ushered in
so much of this stuff we see this all
the time right like so a lot of the
Liberals uh who say nothing as this is
going on and when people 5 years ago
were screaming about this they were
saying you're trans phobes and bigots
then it's starts sort of arriving at
their door and they kind of come around
now I suppose better late than ever but
this this is an interesting video uh
because this is bursting forth not just
in the United States it's happening all
over Western society as you know it's
interesting that it keeps happening in
Western Society isn't that bizarre uh
but here is a video of UK prime minister
Rishi sunak and he's kind of coming
around to biological reality hot diggity
Dam we are going to change this country
and that means life means life now that
shouldn't be a controversial position
the vast majority of hardworking people
agree with it and it also shouldn't be
controversial for parents to know what
their children are being taught in
school about relationships patients
should know when hospitals are talking
about men or women and we shouldn't get
bullied wow UK prime minister sunak
apparently a big Ronda santis guy right
parents should know what's going on we
should accept biolog iCal reality these
are things that should not be debated
anymore like yeah a bunch of us that
were screaming about all of this stuff
and warning that all these weird things
were a coming and by the way there are
more weird things coming because it
never stops right it never stops there
will be something weird after this but
have no doubt the the radical left that
exists in the UK and they have a very
strong radical left they're maybe not
quite as like sort of ubiquitous in
every part of society as we have here
but they will come after Rishi there
there's no doubt about that and how do
we know that well one of the people who
put the trans issue on the map with the
lightest push back ever was once beloved
I mean everyone in the entire country
and all over the world loved this woman
JK Rowling who created Harry Potter of
course and then you may remember some
years ago she basically just said hey
there's biological differences between
boys and girls I'd rather girls not get
you know beat up in boys wrestling that
was in essence what she said on Twitter
let me
this went on on Twitter over the years
I'll read one tweet from her this is
from 2021 she wrote the question at the
heart of this debate is whether sex or
gender identity should be should form
the basis of decisions on safeguarding
provision of services sporting
categories in other areas where women
and girls currently have legal rights
and protections that's just one of many
of the tweets that we could have read of
hers but she talks about it in a very
decent calm way she's quite an
exceptionally good writer and again
beloved by everybody right everybody
loves the Harry Potter things children's
dreams have been made by these books and
then the movies and all she was saying
was hey girls should be protected we
should just have a conversation about
that well I don't have to tell you you
guys know over the last couple years the
the left the woke mob in the UK and
really all over the world has just tried
to destroy her and cancel her they've
tried to remove her name from the books
like just so much insanity and uh well
here we go I was sent this video this
morning this is a radical trans activist
in the UK celebrating the death of JK
Rowling and I saw it so now you have to
see it here we go and people like JK
Rowling need to stop because my
people are dying because of her she
killing us oh she thing about this book
JK rolling she wrote a book she
wrote a book about kill off the queen of
the Turfs it is glorious I only wish
that scene could have been even more
brutal the queen of the turfs that
sounds like a title for a book that's a
book that so Turf what what does Turf
stand for again trans exclusive trans
exclusionary radical trans exclusionary
radical feminist uh this is known as a
woman basically right so she's the queen
of the turf she's the queen of the
people who hates trans people by the way
she's repeatedly said she doesn't hate
trans people it's the same this is what
I mean when Rogan does the soft love
thing or when I try to qualify it with
you know live with dignity and all this
stuff they don't want to give you an
inch these people it's it's very sad you
know in this weird way we can mock these
purple-haired weirdos and all of that
stuff and and to some extent we should
because we have to expose it but in
another way you should have sympathy for
these people because they have they've
been so bludgeoned by an ideology that
was fueled through activism and through
algorithms and tumbler or God knows what
that they end up like like you should be
sympathetic in a weird way to that
person it's just absolutely insane I am
not going to buy that book in case it's
clear I am in case it's not clear I not
going to buy that book all right should
we get to a community Q&A what do you
think oh no we have one oh we do have
one more so related to all of this um
this one isn't specifically about gender
but uh Phoenix saw it this morning it's
been making the rounds again uh this one
sort of pains me a little bit because
Matthew MCC first off I think he's an
absolutely spectacular actor
Interstellar is an incredible movie he
was unbelievable in Wolf Wall Street and
um what was the pop movie uh the pop
movie from 30 years
ago uh not well Dallas Buyers Club he
was great enough but I'm talking about
the the high school one in Dallas uh in
Texas what the come on guys somebody
does anyone have a computer in this room
does anyone the with the weed yeah with
the the girls keep getting younger the
great thing about high school girls is I
keep getting older and they keep getting
younger whatever or they stay the same
age anyone no not Failure to Launch
people we're killing valuable time here
what was the movie and daed and Confused
thank you Jesus all right anyway
generally speaking I like the guy he's
had conversations with Jordan Peterson
he gets it on so much stuff but maybe
this is just part of being Hollywood
being in the Hollywood Machine when
you're in the Hollywood Machine and you
are white and you are a man no matter
how much good work you've done whether
you're married to a apparently nonwhite
woman no matter where where you grew up
and what you must bow to the altar of
racial politics check out this video
this is really
disappointing I heard this term the
other day and I've never heard it before
and I went what and talked to this
person he explained it to
me white
allergies white white allergies that
that by where we were raised and how we
were raised in our history uh growing up
there's certain just imported obvious
ways that we're Prejudice and ways that
that that that we don't eat even
understand we got white allergies and
may not even know it and
so I was sitting there you know looking
at my own life and I sit there and I go
all right tell me mhm Long View High
School was over 50% black I applied to
Grambling I was the first White to ever
work at Catfish Station in all Blues
black blues bar on Sixth Street I am
married to a non-white immigrant I have
black friends all through my life and
still do mhm but what prejudices may I
have via white allergies that I may
not it's so incredible these struggle
sessions he spends the entire time I'm
not a racist my wife's not I got black
friends I worked at a catfish place but
but I still have white allergies I will
say I mean it's also the phrase white
allergies it's so idiotic although I
will say it's hard to picture a black
guy using flones don't you think I feel
like white people only use flones but
that's not because of white allergies
there's just something else going on
there with fload I don't know anyway
it's all stupid this struggle section
session like dude you you're basically
saying hey I've lived my life to the
best of my ability but what what can I
do to bow to you black man and imagine
if if white people started saying black
people have black allergies right like
think how absolutely insane it is and
again I point this out and I and I show
you this video of the purple-haired
woman who wants to murder JK rling only
to illustrate the point that people end
up in these dark places and the only way
that we can help Matthew MCC not have
his white allergies cure him from his
white allergies and the way we can save
the purple-haired girl who wants to
murder JK Rowling and the rest of it is
just by defending the truth it really
it's the only thing we can do and
eventually the cream does rise to the
top on that note let's get to a rubben
report. locals.com community Q&A here we
go pets says if the Democrats think
their best general election chances lie
with a trump matchup isn't tying him up
in legal battles taking a chance that he
may not make it out of the primary or do
they feel his candidacy is inevitable
and are just trying to damage him as
much as possible in the general I think
there's a lot of legit ways you can look
at this thing on one hand I think the
idea that they have hung him up in all
of these cases right this ridiculous I
mean the one in New York which we
covered yesterday is just patently
absurd going after his old businesses
for loans that have been already paid
back for reportedly inflating the prices
of properties and things of that nature
like it's just taking away his uh his
business license making sure he can't do
business so it's like on one hand if you
want to go for him on say the classified
doc stuff and of course that would be a
selective application of the law because
they're not going after Mike Pence
they're not going after Joe Biden with
the the freaking car in the in the you
know Garage in Delaware etc etc that's
bad enough but if you're going to go for
him on all of that stuff you got to
leave him with a business right wouldn't
you want to be like all right we're
going to just kind of scare you on all
this stuff so we'll leave you with your
businesses that you had even before you
were president so that maybe you could
go on and get out of politics but they
seem to be going after the whole thing
my gut feeling on this is they're go if
it wasn't for all of this imagine if
none of these things were happening
right now right so no trials no
indictments no nothing and he was just
running a campaign uh I think things
would look extremely different right now
a i his numbers and again I just simply
don't believe the polls by the way I
would welcome all of you and I want to
start doing this maybe starting next
week every time we see one of these
polls and Trump is up 65 points and
DeSantis is at 12 or whatever it is I I
started looking at a bunch of the polls
that are going around yesterday do you
know that often these polls are of 500
people 500 people I saw one that was
being pushed around yesterday all over
Place 500 people I saw another one that
was being pushed 1,200 people you have
to think who are the types of people
that answer the phone are they going to
this type of person or that type of
person what age is the person that like
all of these things I I just simply
don't believe in these polls but to get
to your question specifically in a weird
way if Trump wasn't going through all of
this stuff he'd be have he'd have to
campaign on his record now his record is
certainly better than the Democrat
record but is it objectively better than
the sanz's record now you might like his
personality more you might like the
off-the-cuff stuff and the humor and the
trolling and all that that's fine but in
an odd way the system is propping him up
right now I would say the argument why
would they prop him up they feel he's
the easiest to beat if he he believes
not if he believes they stole the
election from him last time so he has to
explain why wouldn't they steal it from
you this time and even if you don't
believe the election was stolen from him
last time you got to tell me where the
new voters are so let's say the election
was completely legit there there's one
or two there's one or two options here
either they stole it from him in which
case you got to figure out a way to not
get it stolen from him again or it was
legit and he lost by you know what was
it 81 million to Biden 75 to him so he
has to figure out where do you find new
votes well we know there's a lot of
people now who are tired of trump we
know that there's a whole bunch of
people who will walk over glass to vote
against Trump so where are the where is
the math in that where are the numbers
in that so it's a little hard to tell
what the system is doing right now my
gut feeling is they're propping him up
and keeping him in the news because they
think he's the easiest to beat and there
is some guy out there who could get some
crossover people I think you know who
I'm talking about Amy says we're at the
end of generation alphabet there's Gen X
the yuppies Gen Y the Millennials and
gen Z the Zoomers what should the Next
Generation my kids's generation be
called they have a name my kids have a j
Al gen Alpha we're going that's boring
no I don't like that I don't I don't
think we have to just keep it around
like the letter in a right I don't like
that like I would love it to be like how
about like the the Builder Generation
The Fix It generation the no BS
generation like maybe the kids that are
you know being born now up to say 10
years old who will be born you know
during the time of a push back from like
the true lunacy that I just spent the
opening of the show talking about maybe
they will be the generation and by the
way we see evidence of this even in the
in the Zoomers now who are leaning a
little more conservative right because
they grew up in a time being told by
adults that they couldn't leave their
room and all and had to be injected with
things and God Only Knows after years of
vaccine injuries as they grow up you
know they're going to send a lot of
their parents to very shitty old age
homes uh but I would love to see
whatever you want to call it Alpha Beta
well I don't want to call it beta we'll
call it Alpha is better than beta I
suppose but I would love to see the
generation of my children be the ones
who really come in no BS we got we got
educated in better ways because we
funded uh students instead of systems uh
we got our kids out of all of these
institutions whatever they are the
cultural energy educational institutions
and everything that confused them and
all that stuff and we sent them into the
world to go fix it I guess that well I
suppose that's a challenge for us in Gen
X and Gen Y and uh and even slightly
younger who are the parents of these
kids Frank says who decided Congress
should reconvene next Tuesday and why is
the Republican Congress going along when
the matter of house speaker is so
important right so Congress is off now
for a couple days although obviously
there's going to be a lot of backdoor
deals and everybody's trying to figure
out who the next speaker of the house is
as I mentioned yesterday it does sound
like Jim Jordan is kind of the leading
candidate right now cuz Gates likes him
and a lot of the McCarthy type people
like him as well uh I've interviewed him
a bunch of times I I think he's a a good
dude he gets the issues he's really big
on free speech and fighting big Tech and
all of that stuff but in essence uh they
have pushed all of the meetings to next
week I'm getting some info here from uh
from n from n you're sourcing NPR on the
Reuben report oh my God I'm reading this
on the Fly can't swear to its veracity
uh North Carolina Representative Patrick
McKenry who chairs the financial
services committee has been named
speaker Pro tempor an interterm role
with limited Authority his First Act was
to declare house in recess okay so we
have this temporary guy we're in recess
for a couple days next week I think
we're going to have Thomas Massie who I
referenced yesterday as just kind of one
of the same guys one of the same guys
who I'd like to think is liked by people
on both sides but that's getting harder
and harder but like he just a decent
freaking human being he's also if I'm
not mistaken can you check this is he a
physicist Thomas Massie he built he took
a Tesla car battery and he runs his
entire house on it and he built it
himself he's either a physicist or he's
a mathematician or or something but
anyway and he's just a good man he's
just a good man we were going to try to
have him on tomorrow but then when I
found out that this recess was happening
we're going to push that to next week
and maybe we can get him even if he's
literally walking in the halls of
Congress on his phone uh that that would
be just fine what is he is is he a he
has a ma a master's no he has a Bachelor
of Science degree in electrical
engineering and a master of science
degree in mechanical engineering from
MIT like what the hell's the guy doing
in Congress yeah the guy temporary
speaker yeah apparently his first one of
his first things he did was kick nany
pel is still in the speaker office
McCarthy let her keep it that's
interesting so the guy that we just
referenced that's the temporary speaker
apparently Nancy Pelosi's been hanging
out in the speakers off as he booted her
so all right some good things are
happening there Joe says any guesses on
who will win the World Series this
year believe it or not I have no idea
who's in the World Series the only thing
I know about B oh here we go but before
I even look at that actually the only
thing I know about baseball because I'm
here in Miami is that a week or so ago
the the Marlins were close to getting
the Wild Card did they get it they the
Marlins got it all right Miami there you
go now I'm being shown the breakdown
here let's see
oh the Marlins were eliminated last
night oh Philly oh man they probably
just didn't want to go to Philly it'd
have to live with that filth and fetman
and everything else all right so what am
I looking at here it looks like it will
be Texas Texas playing Baltimore uh
that's Minnesota playing Houston those
are the the Los Angeles Angels of
Anaheim stupidest name ever versus the
LA
Dodgers oh that's the Arizona
Diamondbacks sorry see I'm I'm out of
the loop man and then we got the
Phillies vers the A's you know what in
this uh in this studio here in this
office here we only have one major
baseball guy Connor was a big- time
baseball player he loves baseball
lifelong Dodgers guy you trying to go to
Every uh Stadium right how many do you
have
left probably oh he's still got half the
stadiums to go but he's I don't let
these people ever leave the studio so
that's pretty good but he's a big
Dodgers I'm going to go with the Dodgers
I'm going to re time for Dodger
baseball you've been waiting to roll
that one in for a long time all right
we're a Dodgers we're a Dodgers family
around here I yeah I have no idea I
don't know what's going is Jeter still
playing like that
guy Buttercup says do you have days
where you feel like we are living in a
reality show that there are producers
who are injecting chaos and drama into
the political and cultural worlds yes
what is one of the phrases that I say
all the time and I really want you guys
to to Google and learn about kayfabe k a
y f a this is the idea that professional
wrestling came up with decades ago think
about Andre the Giant fighting Hulk
Hogan Jake the Snake Roberts fighting
Ravishing Rick Roode and the storylines
that went along with that Ravishing Rick
Rood is cheating on Jake The Snake's
wife and banging her on the side Jake
better throw the snake on him and this
what like and you they create this story
that never ends right these stories link
and they go over years and comebacks and
you're angry at this one and and we all
knowing it's fake knowing it's a
production we're still and I used to
love uh w ww it was WWF at the time WWE
wrestling and I I would go I've been to
Madison Square Garden I think I was at
WrestleMania I would not four four was
the big one with Hogan finally taking
out Andre the Giant maybe six something
like that but anyway uh the idea that we
all go to these things you know you're
watching something fake and you're
having all of these real emotions it
does sometimes feel we are in some sort
of uh Truman Show if you saw the movie
Truman Show with Jim Carry that we're
just in some sort of like orchestrated
reality and all responding into it all
the time it's one of the reasons that I
try my best and and probably fail at it
sometimes to not have you guys be out
outraged all the time right right I'll
reference what people are outraged about
and occasionally I can get a little
annoyed about something fortunately no
clips of The View today but like we're
all just like in this thing you remember
when when Barbie came out what was that
two three months ago and everybody on
the right was screaming and ranting and
raving about Barbie it's like man you
guys are just reacting to everything I'm
not defending Barbie I did not see
Barbie Believe it or or not you loved
bar Brock loved how have I hired you
people it really makes me wonder
sometimes but anyway like just we don't
want to be just reacting to everything
all the time and that's what it does
feel like like there's just a script
they inject a little craziness when they
need a little craziness or a little
shiny thing over there to distract us
and that's kind of why as I often say we
end up on the slow descent to hell we
don't know how to deal with real issues
we don't know how to respond when we get
you know decent leaders out there
because There's No Business Like Show
Business there's no business I know all
right Candace says uh I'm going to I'm
going uh oh I'm going back to SoCal next
week for a friend's wedding is it that
bad I already can't wait to come back to
North Carolina listen you stay in North
Carolina you don't go you don't go oh we
should have played the Cala don't go
Trump I'm GNA come um yeah I mean it's
bad it's bad it depends where you're
going you know look LA area it's just
bad don't go to I would say truly don't
go to Hollywood West Hollywood it's
disaster there's virtually no one there
the stores are all closed homeless
people drugs like it's it's not San
Francisco level but it's bad obviously
there's some other areas like if you go
to Belair where the super rich people
live if you're in La you're going to be
okay in belir if you go to belir I don't
know if it's still open there was an
awesome jazz club I used to go to it's
like the only thing I miss from La it
was called vbr it was owned by Herb
Alpert remember Herb Alpert uh did rise
and a whole bunch of other stuff like
legendary Jazz guy and he had a great
Club there that I used to go to but but
the place yeah the place itself it just
it just ain't great it is what it is
Dyan says are you as disappointed in the
congressman who didn't support Matt
Gates I think they should have kicked
McCarthy to the curb when he folded on
Ukraine the January 6 tapes and the
budget to name a few look I am
completely with Gates on a on a bunch of
this stuff like the the one item votes
like instead of all of the pork right
and that if you don't vote for the you
know they basically put out a border
wall and somehow you say okay I do want
to fund the border wall you ended up
also giving Ukraine 200 billion insane
funding the gender studies in Pakistan
as I've talked about all of these crazy
like these things that you cannot
believe literally looking at the
genitals of turtles and and all of the
weird things that they're up to that
wasn't a Mitch McConnell joke that was
just a straightup turtle comment um I'm
with him on that funding of Ukraine
obviously he said McCarthy said he was
going to release the January 6 tapes as
far as I know they didn't you know
Tucker I guess has them I I don't know
if he's still going through them or
whatever else um I'm not I'm not I can't
say I'm disappointed or angry at the
people that didn't go along with this
you got to remember about about what was
it you know 150 some odd Republicans did
not go along with it ate did and cut
some kind of deal with the Devil with
the Democrats to get rid of McCarthy and
that's fine and again as I said
yesterday I'm not saying McCarthy is
great but I would reference the the
speech that we played yesterday of
Thomas Massie basically saying hey I've
been around for a while
I've seen guys like John Boehner who
didn't do anything when they were
speaker I've seen guys like Paul Ryan
who the magabe hates Paul Ryan right who
didn't do anything when they were
speaker he said this has been the most
conservative Congress you may not like
all of it and this again goes to uh a
concept that we will constantly be
talking about I think for the next year
and a half and maybe for the remaining
period of time that America exists as a
nation it's like do you want to burn it
all down and just roll the dice and see
what happens on the other side and make
maybe it's better right there there's a
lot of screwy stuff maybe it's better on
the other side or do you want to take
something that was really hard to build
and precious and whatever and it's and
it's infected with lobbyists and all
that stuff and figure out how to
marginally make it better that was the
McCarthy View and Gates has a different
view so I'm not angry at those people
Jennifer says how did you propose to
David uh I did it it was a surprise one
I believe it was a Sunday evening uh
right before Thanksgiving this is
2014 was 2014 2 yeah 2014 man we've been
together a long time um and we were
together like five or six years before
that um I said to him get in the car I
said put on a nice shirt get in the car
let's just take a drive I was like ah
maybe we'll get dinner somewhere we're
driving driving driving then we start
getting to like more shady part of La
we're kind of in like the Compton area
you don't go to dinner in Compton and
it's getting weird or whatever and then
uh he sees that we we're turning into
the forum the forums where the Lakers
used to play they don't use it for
sports anymore I don't think it's it's
now just for concerts and things of that
nature he did not see any of the signs
outside and he's like he's looking at me
like are you taking me to a Star Wars
convention is that what we're doing
right now that's what he thought we were
doing and we get in there and it was uh
Fleetwood Mac and Fleetwood Mac is his
favorite uh band loves Stevie Nicks
loves all of them and then the third
song I had already checked the playlist
from the night before so I thought the
third song was going to be dreams which
is his favorite song proposed to him
there and I gotta tell you uh there is
nothing for heterosexual people as
exciting as seeing gay people get
engaged I mean the Ovation we got like
it just started spreading throughout the
thing may maybe it was because uh you
know Stevie was spinning but I think it
was because of us I'm not sure anyway
which that's actually gayer honestly
Stevie Nick spinning around stage uh
Richard says uh do you think Jim Jordan
can carry the votes to be speaker I feel
he could have at the beginning of the
session but only bowed out of
consideration in difference uh in
difference or difference to McCarthy
meaning he could have got it the first
time around and he can yeah he did bow
out last time I think he can get it
because he's really liked by the Trump
contingent um he's like like I don't
know who really doesn't like him I think
he's thought of as like a pretty decent
guy and at this point you know let's say
you're one of the
McCarthy uh Republicans or whatever you
want to call them you now know that
because Gates is willing to team with
the Dems you now know you got to get
somebody that they're going to come on
board with otherwise they'll just
Stonewall you to high hell so Jim Jordan
happens to be in that lane so my gut
feeling like it doesn't tell much of a
story here because I think it's going to
be the guy most people think it's going
to be but I think it's going to be Jim
Jordan uh oldw World charm says people
are saying that this move to OU McCarthy
will have us lose the house in 24 was
this a really bad chess move I mean who
knows who knows
look the Democrats blow but the
Republicans suck that's where we're at
clip that one um that's really where
we're at with things like I I don't know
I don't know who's looking at the
Republicans right now like oh what a
what a great group what a powerful group
of people I think there's a little juice
to what Gates has done and it's
deservingly so I fully give him credit
for that by the way we reached out to
his people yesterday we're already in
touch with him so we're trying to make
an interview happen we'll see about that
um but you know I said it to to a friend
this morning I was texting a friend old
old high school friend asking me about
my thoughts on this stuff and he's like
you know what these Republicans and D
it's like they destroy each other the
Democrats are in lock step now now like
these eight guys are using the Dems it's
like it's and I was just like look you
know I never considered myself a
republican in my entire life I am a
newly registered Republican here in the
State of Florida I consider myself a
Florida Republican but as for the wider
operation I'm certainly not a Democrat
but I'll vote for for the few people
every now and again who are decent and
generally a lot of these people just are
not chipster says has Dave never had a
waterburger if so what's his opinion yes
I had waterburger a couple times uh it's
been a few years I think the last time
was in Texas somewhere maybe it was in
Tennessee if I'm not mistaken uh pretty
good it's like it's like a big kind of
just like juicy a little kind of sloppy
Burger my preference always I mean I
still you know I mentioned the LA thing
before and the Jazz Club I do miss in
and out that is the one thing I miss we
got our Shake Shack here I find Shake
Shack to be it's a little greasy little
little greasy I don't know what that's
all about what would you say is the best
burger in Miami what would you guys say
you like that Burger Five place right I
had it the other day I didn't think it
was that great you got anything what do
you
got Brock you got a burger I feel like
you got a burger fast fast food best I
got five guys over here from Brock
Connor local local there's a place
called local in Coconut Grove if you
ever want to see Connor he hangs out
there all day long talking about the
Dodgers if you want to have a nice meal
of a burger and a conversation about the
Dodgers that's where you go um yeah
water burer pretty good pretty good
laielli says why was Russia running a
test at the same time as FEMA yesterday
were they up to something together so I
did not know that and I had to double
check it right before the show so
everybody knows your phone just
basically blew up what time was that
yesterday about 3:00 or so the phone
just blew up like I was literally
holding Luke like trying to get him to
take a nap I forgot that the thing was
going to go off I just like you know so
yeah so they they just want to know that
they can control us at any the aliens
have landed get in your basement okay
but apparently the Russians we did check
the Russians ran a test at the exact
same
time like who does that better me or the
rock um yeah I mean I don't know that
gets us back to the kayf thing before
like it all feels like a script John
says Dave you have no problem with
calling balls and strikes would you
criticize Dan santis when he needs to be
criticized absolutely absolutely I think
actually you know on that abortion thing
where he's done the six week thing and
we had 15 weeks here in Florida and I've
said many times I didn't I go to every
Republican event in Florida basically I
did not or conservative event whatever
you want to say I uh never heard any
conservative or republican complaining
about the abortion situation here I
think there were a whole bunch of people
that had their own personal beliefs that
wish it would have been earlier or no
abortions altogether uh I think he did
what he thought was right I happen to
disagree with him on that beyond that I
don't know I I don't think I have any
criticisms of him on policy I I'm I'm
living proof I mean my life and my
businesses and everything here are are
an example of why Florida is so good
which is directly related to him and how
he not only won in landslides but has
completely restructured the parties here
there's basically no Democrat Party here
in uh Florida anymore so he's done
incredible stuff on that if I was to
criticize him on anything else I guess
maybe there was a way to roll out this
campaign a little bit better I think
maybe and I'm not I'm not even sure
about that you know the Trump thing is
such a freaking X Factor I I don't know
what else they could have done but I
suppose you know I'd have to ask him
personally and I will next time I see
him but in retrospect did they not
realize that Trump was going to throw
the kitchen sink at them not just you
know do like standard like Oppo research
like did you have an affair with your
wife but basically like lie about
everything everything related to Florida
related to co related to Soros and all
of the things Trump has lied about like
whether whether we can expose those
things or not a certain amount of people
believe them and maybe there was a
better force field related to some of
that that they needed to Think Through
beforehand but I would welcome your
thoughts on that I mean I'm just trying
to think like on policy like it's it's
all there I know him to be a good guy
like he doesn't he doesn't lie in in at
least you know within the within the
parameters of being a public official so
but I'm open to it if you guys got
anything else uh if you have not
subscribed at rumble.com Ruben report
please do you never know when YouTube is
going to give us the boot uh if you want
to join us for a postgame show right now
for a few extra questions comments and
queries it's Ruben report. locals.com of
course we have a Apple iOS app and an
Android uh app which is at the Google
Play Store uh tomorrow we've got the
panel back we've got Libby Emmons and
Sarah Gonzalez from The Blaze and Libby
from post millennial we leave you this
is an oldie but a goodie some people
that you don't see much of these days
but they're still around apparently and
we'll see everybody on the other side
two minutes early I know you love it I
know people are watching I did not you
loved it you owe me a minute and 19 give
it to you I'll give it to
[Music]
you